okay
so we're now recording so this is going
to be recorded and uh
the video will be posted online in the
next day or two
so uh welcome to the
galaxy webinar on connecting galaxy with
the nih
sequence read archive sra
um i'm dave clements i
am one of the training and outreach
people for the galaxy project
uh today we also have marius vandenbeek
and dan blankenberg
we're going to join in in addition we
have a number of people from the sra
itself
who are going to chime in as we go
correcting us as
we do things or adding additional
information so
um the slides that we're using today
we're not going to spend a whole lot of
time in slides first of all but the
slides do have links in them so that
makes them
useful the slides are at that url
at the bottom so bitly galaxy dash
sra slides in their google slides
so
let's see there we go okay
so our agenda is short and sweet uh
we're gonna
introduce sra we're gonna introduce
galaxy and then we're gonna talk about
sra and galaxy and we're gonna do that
via a live demo
please ask questions as we go so there's
a
q a window in zoom it should be there
should be a q a
icon at the bottom of your zoom window
click on that type your question
everyone can see your question um
whoever is not speaking will try
and collate those and then throw them at
the current speaker
so if your question doesn't get asked
immediately please be patient
and it will be asked time allowing
and we want to cover questions as we go
we can also cover questions at the end
but um we're all big fans of questions
as we go
so okay so
when you registered we asked is there
anything you would like to specifically
learn about in this webinar
we got a whole range of options um some
of which we're going to cover today and
some of which were not
so we are going to talk about sra and
galaxy
and we're going to focus on the parts of
sra and galaxy that have to do with that
interaction
so everything in the today column we
should be covering
things in the not today covering sorry
things in the not today column we could
cover
but not today we don't have time so we
can do all these things
in sra or in galaxy
but we're not going to discuss those
today we will give you some
some pointers on how to get more
information about
things like that and lastly we had one
person god bless you whoever you are who
said the meaning of life
and i do like to think you could find
that in sra and galaxy and maybe we will
maybe we won't but um we'll try okay
so that's what we're going to cover so
let's talk about
the sra um sequence read archive so the
first thing i'm going to try and do a
poll
pull can i do a poll here um
oh it's only giving me one pole i don't
want that pole
crap okay so my first poll has gone
gone awry already okay
uh
let's see well we're just not gonna pull
you guys sorry
um okay so
what i was gonna do is ask how many
people have experience
with sra and how deep is that experience
i'm going to assume that you have a
little bit of experience
with sra i'm going to do the walk
through in the sra part
and marius is going to do the walk
through the galaxy part i had another
poll or so i thought
um to ask about galaxy and your
experience with that
um so but we're just going to plow ahead
under the assumption that you
have used sra but you may or may not be
an expert
so so what is sra um it's part of ncbi
which is part of nih and it's the
primary archive of
unassembled reads so it doesn't have
final assemblies it doesn't have
reference sequence what it has is reads
so things that come off the instruments
and that distinction is worth keeping in
mind this is where you go when you want
access to the source
data for reference reader yeah for
reference sequence
things that are in genbank this is where
you find the evidence behind it
so it's a great place to get you know i
just said that okay so another point
um all of sra every bit of it is now on
amazon web services
and google compute so it's all in the
cloud
this means you can have fast access to
it
it's a very powerful feature and it's
relatively recent
one note you will also hear referred to
as the short read archive
its former name it hasn't been the short
read archive for a long time
but i'm older than that so occasionally
i'll call it short read archive and i
apologize for that it is not just for
short reads
it has all kinds of reasoning okay
so and um sra folks again please feel
free to chime in and say well actually
um and we'll see up strong window
okay so um
today we're going to spend our time in
sra in two things
one is entree and one is the sra run
selector entree
is a query interface that's used across
a lot of ncbi
resources so you may already be familiar
with it even if you don't think you are
and the sra run selector is a newer
method
of interacting with sra data we're going
to use both
they complement each other um they don't
replace each other
they complement each other so
okay and i'm going to throw this slide
at one of the sra folks
or maybe i won't
so uh i will my name is yuris kripchenko
and i wanted to let everybody know
that um sorry is going through some
changes
and um we would really love to have
community feedback on those changes that
we're thinking about doing
and so we have this request for
information
open um so please go to the
link on the slide and provide us
your feedback on our plans for the
changes that we're thinking of doing
um i think it's very important to get
the community's feedback
to make sure that the things we're doing
matches your expectations and
in the long term will help you perform
science faster and better and provide
kind of more research opportunities uh
for everybody
thank you if you're part of the galaxy
community
that link is also available in the june
newsletter
and we've tweeted it a couple times on
our on our
twitter feed we've actually retweeted it
from ncbi
so you can find that on twitter as well
so let's talk about galaxy again rough
introduction before we dive into the
actual hands-on part
the galaxy is a data integration and
analysis platform
and it's funded for and developed for
life scientists
it's actually used in all sorts of
things um
but that's our goal is to be for life
science
we are in addition to being that
platform we're a worldwide community and
we really can't stress that enough the
community is what makes galaxy what it
is
um and it's not just the coders the
developers it's the users people who do
training
uh people who provide infrastructure
it's a huge very vibrant community and
without a galaxy
would probably not be around anymore so
um i'd like yeah so like to stress both
those things they're equally important
the platform and the people okay
galaxy's available
in a whole bunch of different ways
there are over a hundred free online web
servers out there
something like 140 30 the last i knew
um if you follow that first url at the
bottom you'll go to the platform
directory
it's also available in commercial and
academic clouds so you can easily launch
it on
amazon or if you're in the us you can
easily launch it on jet stream
people have published it in containers
so docker and virtual machines so you
can launch it on your
laptop very easily it's also open source
software that can be installed anywhere
and that is the most common use case for
galaxies it's installed all over the
world
at research institutions universities
usually behind firewalls
but that is our most popular deployment
so
okay we also have a lot of training
materials and we wrote a tutorial um
to highlight how to use sra and we'll
we'll use that later today
um but there is a huge library again
this is part of a community effort this
is entirely run by the community
to publish tutorials on how to use
galaxy for different domains
and all sorts of topics there
epigenetics genome annotation
we also have tutorials on galaxy basics
like data manipulation user interface
in addition we have tutorials on how to
write tutorials
uh which was very useful for the three
of us in the last few days
and we also have tutorials on how to run
a galaxy server
so it's a very robust library of
training materials
and something like 160 people have
contributed so far
to that okay
so today we're going to do a live demo
we're going to use a covid19
example um but that domain doesn't
actually matter
what we're demonstrating today is how to
use sra and it doesn't have to be viral
reads or
gathering from sra it can be anything it
can back rna-seq experiments it can back
ship seek experiments you name it
if it's an sra we can get it into galaxy
with what we're going to show you today
so and a rough plan is we're going to go
from galaxy to sra to galaxy
to get metadata and then we're going to
go back to sra
well we're going to run a tool that goes
back to sra to grab the actual data
itself and then we're going to run a
short suite analysis in galaxy that uses
the sra data
now the second link at the bottom there
may or may not work yet um i don't know
unless
it works yes okay so reverse that it
works it's brilliant because we're on
the ball
okay um so the second link will take you
to that tutorial
and i'm not going to go step through
step in that tutorial but that's
basically the process that me and marius
are doing today
is what's in that tutorial okay
so um a couple of caveats before we
do this um so sra
is this wonderful resource chock full of
data and it's growing rapidly as you may
know
but submitters don't often provide
complete or correct metadata and we may
see that
in some of our exploration today um
there's a discrepancy between srr and
err entries
um does anybody want to expand on what
that is
yes uh so actually i don't know maybe
yuri can correct me uh but
something well there are several places
where uh
primary data is is deposited
so there is a short-range archive here
at ncbi
there is also short trade archive in
european um
under amble umbrella european nucleotide
archive
and so they sometimes especially for
for starscoff2data because it's it's
it's released essentially on a daily
basis they're not always in sync
so for example if you're uh trying to
pull err
european accessions from sra from here
sometimes that does not work
so there is some discrepancy here and
also
in some cases when you are trying to
download really large sets
of um of of reads thousands of rigs and
some of them may statistically fail for
a variety of reasons uh most most often
for uh
network connectivity uh reasons yeah so
the tool we're gonna use today is
actually built to deal with that
we won't i'm pretty sure we won't see
that today because we're doing very
small data sets in a small number
but the tool is actually built to be
rerun and just get the things that fail
so okay
and i think yeah okay so let's go back
here i'm gonna get out of this escape
and let's go to the galaxy training
if i go there what happens okay
let me know if my screen share is no
longer behaving
is it still behaving yes okay
good okay i'm gonna zoom in just a tad
plus let's do one more
plus okay so this is the tutorial
um it's yeah so it uses stars cooker
yeah
it uses covet as an example but again it
doesn't actually
matter for what we're talking about
today okay
so i'm gonna scroll down it's a typical
tutorial some leading questions some
objectives
um what are requirements all sorts of
things
and the aim and the agenda you'll see as
we go through
there's lots of text there's comments
there's tips there's also these hands
on so if you're already familiar with
sra and galaxy
and you know what you're doing you just
want to learn how to do it
you want to focus on just the hands-on
parts of these tutorials
okay if you're
learning either or both of those it
might pay to actually read the tutorial
in which case it'll take you longer
but hopefully it contains some useful
insight
okay so what we're going to do again is
we're going to go to use galaxy.org
and from there we're going to go to sra
we're going to explore sra for a while
and then we're going to send data
back to galaxy so let's do that and
we're going to start out in
andre so let's do this
okay so this is going to land us on
usedgalaxy.org
which is i'm going to zoom in just a tad
okay um which is the galaxy server run
by the project
in the us so again anybody can set up
their own galaxy server there are over
public ones this is the one for the
galaxy that the galaxy team in the us
runs okay it might be the largest one in
the world
i think okay so it's a three panel
interface over here you have your tools
in the middle um once we get going
you'll see data sets
and tools so we run our tools from the
middle and we also preview
and view our data sets here third panel
is the history
so this is what we've done and so far it
says hey dave yours your history is
empty
and it says you can do stuff so cool i
will do stuff
okay and in fact what i'm going to do is
get data from an external source
and so the very first thing i do is i
come over here and it's like okay what i
want to do i want to get data from sra
so i'm going to click on that
and get data download and extract okay
this stuff looks great
because this is what i want to do but
if i click on well yeah eventually i'll
click on that but right now what i want
to do is go to the sra server
because i don't yet know the details of
what i want i actually want to go to sra
and figure out exactly what i want so
i'm going to click on that
sra server and now it transfers me i'm
going to zoom in
galaxy into sra now for right now
um this feature is available on
usedgalaxy.org
support for this feature is in the 20.05
release
which has not yet come out but the
release of that is imminent
and once it's in the 2005 release we'll
see it start to filter out to other
galaxy servers as well
but right now it's only in use
galaxy.org and so
what's happening behind the scenes is
when i said hey go to the sra server
it goes from galaxy to sra and it tells
it which server it came from
and sra is going to remember that and in
the end when i ship stuff back it
remembers what server i came
now again as of right now there's only
one server but eventually you'll be able
to call this from any server that
supports sra
okay so we're an sra and this is the
entree interface which may look familiar
if you've used ncbi
or sra before and you can type anything
here and so
i'm going to borrow something from yuri
because yuri likes dolphins and so we're
gonna search for dolphin
okay and it comes back and it gives us
720 results
and we go down and there's a lot of them
and that's cool
okay so i know great it's kind of
working
and then i get kind of curious and i go
okay well
i used to work on a kidney project so i
like to search for dolphin kidneys
and note that it looks different now
okay
there's only one match for dolphin
kitten okay
and it's this one so it didn't display
it as a list it just took me directly to
it
and it might be pretty old because it's
four five four
well that's cool okay so i got dolphins
i got dolphin kidneys if i type
kidney i go back
and there we go now i've got 124 000
entries so a lot more than i did for
dolphin okay
often i can spell so if i go back to
doll
doll fin i have a mechanical keyboard
which is why you can hear me type i get
720.
okay now there's a bunch of things we
could so yeah i type dolphinitel i type
kidney i could also go into the advanced
query form right here this is a query
builder so
if you're familiar with entree it has a
very sophisticated and powerful syntax
for specifying exactly what you want
um and you can specify it in very
particular fields so
author i only want to see entries from
this you know from this author
maybe from this biosample bio project uh
maybe i'm only interested in homo
sapiens uh i only want to see things
that are recent or that are old who
knows
um there's a bunch of things you can put
in here and you can build this
incredibly complex query
and then it will put it into entree
syntax which
is difficult to remember but you can use
this form
to create it okay so we could
today use this advanced form
to create our query okay now we're not
going to
um what we're going to do instead
is we're going to search for sars
see if i can remember this cov2
okay and that's what we actually want to
run today
sorry cov2 and we note we have 25
000 entries okay we're on page one of
1200 pages so that's kind of a lot of
data
okay and now we could
narrow things down here further we could
say
okay i want to see stuff from egypt or
from thailand or from wherever
i could do that here i'm not going to
because
what i want to do is switch to the run
selector interface
okay so the run selector
complements entree as i mentioned
earlier but it's a lot friendlier
okay so we're going to switch to that
i'm going to send all 25 000 of these
which is
way too many to use in a tutorial
probably way too many to use in any
meaningful experiment that we're going
to run but
maybe so i'm going to click on send
results to run selector
right there and this is going to take me
to a different interface
all 25 000
okay here we are
there's our runs oh so something to note
when we were in s sorry so back in
entree
we had a number of entries
and it wasn't this number it was a
different number
and the reason that number is different
is because in entree we're looking at
sra experiments okay and an experiment
is a package that wraps a bunch of
things including runs now we're
interested in
runs because that's where the sequence
data is
so this number is different it's usually
going to be larger because experiments
typically have
well they don't typically have they can
have one or more runs
okay and here it's a little bit larger
okay
so don't expect this number to be the
same because we've now gone
from experiments to runs it's the same
data we're just seeing it in more detail
okay so that's what this is and it says
hey we got a lot of stuff here
we got a tariff 1.8 terabytes 3.9
terabases
uh something to note is we have this
tantalizing galaxy button here but it's
not
currently active so our goal is to make
that active and sensitive
now in entree we could type in searches
which get very sophisticated and narrow
in on things
with run selector it provides a faceted
search interface which is over here in
the filters list
okay so that's what this is and these
items correspond to columns now if we
scan this
we have a lot of metadata about all of
our 25 000 runs
it goes over and over and over that's a
huge amount of stuff
okay and a lot of these columns
are reflected here and they show up in
the filters list
if we if they are suitable for faceted
search which is what we're using columns
that are suitable for faceted search are
two types of columns
one is it has a limited number of
discrete
values okay so let's see
um assay type let's click on that for
instance so i just clicked on asset type
and it shows me down here okay i've got
one two three four
five six seven eight different values
for assay type
now if essay type had 3 000 values
it wouldn't show up in this list because
i
because the run selector can't build a
meaningful interface from 3 000
values okay but it has a limited number
there's a default you can control
with this cog okay that says well i want
more than 10
i want 15 or 20. i don't think you can
say 3 000.
okay um but this allows us to say i only
want to see things that are amplicon
okay and you can click on that and now
it's going to narrow this list
we went from 24 960 down to 21 000.
maybe i want to throw an rna-seq as well
and now that number goes up again and
then i decide oh actually i want to drop
the amplicons
okay and now i'm down to 1800 items
again
okay i can also do what uh
let's see i don't know i don't know
what's in cell type let's take a look
okay so i clicked on cell type and now i
come down here and i've got tracheal
i've got empty
and maybe i'm particularly interest yeah
i'm in particularly interest in lung
adenocarcinoma
hopefully i pronounce that correctly so
i click on that
and so now i've got the intersection
of rnac and
lung adenocarcinoma and i've got 56
items which are both of those
okay now before i click that
i had a lot of numbers here these are
subsets within this
set so if i unclick that
these numbers do they change oh they
don't change okay
i take that all back okay um
okay so you can play with this and you
can make your
your um queries as as sophisticated as
you want
now this is built as a query interface
but it's also a great interface for
understanding the data
so we've got 25 000 rows here
you don't want to spend hours going
through essay type columns or paging
through this to see what the different
options are you just want to type on
asset click
and say what's in here okay so acid type
is
kind of you know it's kind of an easily
understood thing even for me a
non-biologist
but there are also things like uh well i
don't
isolation source post assessment
probably associated
i don't know what that means but i come
here and i can
maybe figure it out maybe i have enough
background to figure out what this means
isolation source hosted associated so
there are many columns here where it's
not exactly clear what's going on
and you can use the run selector to
explore your data
okay so
it's a much friendlier interface okay
now today
since we're running a workshop we're not
going to do any of that what we're gonna
do is get a very small
sample okay and uh
let's see oh i skipped the head right
there
okay we're gonna do a very small sample
and
we're gonna just cut and paste this into
the found item search box
okay now in reality this is not what
you're going to do with the run selector
the run selector exists so you can do
sophisticated queries
but we're doing a workshop today and
yeah it's just not going to happen we
need these four items
now these are pre-selected let's see
marius is going to explain them
um but oops sorry wrong one these are
pre-selected
um to get us some geographic variation
so let's see let's go back here
and i could paste this you know the same
string
into entree and i would get the same
results
but from entree i can't ship things to
galaxy i have to go to the run selector
first
okay oops where'd it go
i typed clear on that search
yes okay so now we've got these four
and these four are hand picked again for
the you know let's see for the tutorial
so again you wouldn't do this in reality
note that galaxy is still not
highlighted so how are we going to get
galaxy highlighted
in this case i want all of these so i'm
going to click on that
if i only wanted a few of these i would
click individually
boom boom but i want all of them
okay no questions yet good well that's
not good but no questions okay
so note until we do that that's not
highlighted as soon as i highlight any
of these
i can ship it to galaxy so that's what
i'm going to do
um sra folks is there anything that
should be highlighted
before we bounce out of sra the run
selector
no i think you're good but um you might
want to select
those four individually
sorry okay so why is that yuri
just looks like you have
the entire data set selected
and not just the four
so when you look at under the selected
tab
it looks like it says 24 000 is selected
wow okay
one two three four
thank you ah okay see i didn't know that
mary i could have had a disaster here
where we stand
where we spent the rest of our lives
waiting for 24 000 items to go
thank you yuri okay
it's just metadata yes it wouldn't have
been
catastrophic that's true
oh yeah so marius's point is we wouldn't
actually send 1.8 terabytes we would
actually send
let's see metadata for 1.8 terabytes
okay
thank you for saving our day okay
so with that we're gonna head back to
galaxy so let's click on that
we head back to galaxy and a couple of
things happen we get that big green box
and it goes away
okay if you're not familiar with galaxy
that big green box is
necessary but it's not sufficient and
what it means
is that we've had a handshake between
sra and galaxy
and if you get data from ucsc or
anywhere else that's what that big green
box means it means we had a handshake
and the handshake went okay
okay it does not mean we have your data
yet
and so as we can see here um we're in
galaxy we have an unnamed history it no
longer says dave you got nothing it says
oh there's this thing called sra now
that little
icon that clock icon says hey your
request is queued it hasn't started yet
right now it's transferring the data so
we're actively talking back and forth
between galaxy and sra and the data's
coming over
and now we actually have the data in
galaxy
um can i take over here
yes you should
[Music]
share your screen yeah details man okay
i'm gonna stop sharing if i can figure
it out
okay i have stopped sharing marius
and people please ask questions we don't
have any yet
um which implies that so um i've done
the same thing that they just
i've did only three data sets and that's
what we have in the current version of
the tutorial uh
that we've been changing
so okay so this is um the metadata
that we got from the sra you see here a
small preview
that you can scroll but of course if you
click on the i item
the data set will load and
you see here that we uh we have this
first line the header
and then we have the most important
thing that we're interested in
is the run accession so this is some
first column
and we have all the metadata that we
already saw
in the run selected so this is now
within galaxy and we can see
these data sets come from the three
different countries and
that is why i have picked them
so this is not yet the entire dataset as
it is on the sra this is just the
metadata
so the next step is we need to download
the
data and to do that we will use
the download
[Music]
um so yeah we have to download
now with this metadata file we can
download the actual datasets so
what we want to use and again you can
follow the tutorial
uh that spells this out a little bit
slower
you want to use this tool so on the slab
part as
dave said this is the two uh
panel so here are all your tools and
they are grouped within sections
but you can also search so this
was called faster download
okay
[Music]
okay and there are multiple options
on how you can download the data set so
if you already
have the accession you just need to
download a single accession
you could type it in like this one here
um
and i would download the single datasets
that is also useful
if you know the accessions because for
instance you're redoing the analysis of
the paper
but here we want to focus on the data
that we just selected
um so for that you um click
here on this and that's select input
type
and we select list of srn sessions and
since this is the only data set we have
in your history
it is automatically selected but if it
was not
you would hear you'll be able to click
here and choose the data set that you
would like
so we can do that
so what happened here this is the
history
in the history data sets appear as they
are being generated so
um gray means that the data set is
new and galaxy has sent them off to the
computing facilities but
um that's happening now and as soon as
they are running they will be
orange and then they will turn green um
all right so we saw this here um
okay so we're going to do variant
analysis
and something can only be the barrier if
we have the corresponding reference
so we need to download the reference
data
um so typically you would fetch the
reference data
from the ncbi resources so
they host the reference genome but for
this tutorial we've also uploaded the
reference sequence to zimono which is an
archive
for scientific data um so you can get
the
url from the tutorial
okay so um
we have received this data set through
the sra survey itself but if you want to
upload any other data set
this is the main way to upload data into
galaxy
so this opens this model and there are
multiple ways to
add data sets you can upload them from
your computer you can upload files for
ftp
or if it's simple data or urls you can
just paste them
so in our case um we can paste the
record here we can give it a name
[Music]
and as with the sra data sets that we're
currently downloading here
we're also downloading the reference
team
so the download is finished there is a
log file so we found
three times two data sets which makes
sense
because the data sets that we have
selected
are paired and data sets that were
generated
with illumina sequencing so here and
that we lay out the
the disappear data sets and if we
look in the output of the sra
download tool we see that these are in
here
so i have to say one more thing this is
a normal data set
this is a collection and so connections
are collections
of data sets are grouped together so you
can see here
we have these three different accessions
and we can drill down
into this connection and we can go
deeper and we see that we have a forward
and a reverse
familiar with you know variant
sequencing this should
make a lot of sense
we can also take a quick look this is a
compressed file but galaxy knows
how to display these compressed files
and if you've ever seen a fascia file
that's familiar so you give you
your sequence your header lines and
the encoded quality
okay so now we have the
data sets and we have the reference
genome
um so we can continue with the analysis
one thing
that is important to do in this type of
analysis and in general restriction of
sequencing adapters
these don't contain biological
information so we need to get rid of
them for this we can use a
tool we have many different tools and
again there are tutorials on this
in this case we will use a tool called
class p
and uh we have paired and data so we
need to select
pair and we have another connection so
we need to say
paired collection and there is only one
paired correction in history so it has
been
pre-selected but otherwise if there were
multiple data sets here
yeah we have a question uh
from pablo cataldo should we download
and process data from single and paired
ends
separately in galaxy yeah uh so it is
not necessary if this was a mix
of single and paradigm data sets you
would get the paradigm data set here and
this
dataset there in
practical terms we often separate them
so that we can
run a series of analysis we can
run workflows which are a series of
analysis
and then we first pick the variant data
sets and then the signal data sets
because they may need different
parameters but
in principle there is you can balancing
it and repair them
and it doesn't have to be illumina um it
can be anything that the sra costs
so i'll show you them for iron toilet um
that's a good thanks thank you
okay so um fast p generates this
pair and output and it generates
html report as well now
um i didn't follow the tutorial and
that's not good
[Music]
in fact what we should have done is run
fast but
um and then we would like to output the
json report because
after we're done with the analysis we
will use
this so we get the html report which is
beautiful
and we get a json report which is
machine leader which will use later on
to generate a bigger review folder
um we need to select the correct
uh input data set as well
we selected the fast p output
not a problem
galaxy is very patient it's very good
for domestic
and the real pro trick here is that
once you know what you are doing um you
can generate a workflow to
not need to think about this and just do
what you want to do
all right so um the first
sorry the first uh run here has
completed
um but we're missing the json report
but we can already take a look at this
so we see that there's a quick overview
of what the trimming has done
there's some statistics so
most of the bases are really good so use
the quality and the more
high quality basis you have the better
and again there are more extensive
tutorials on how to interpret this
kind of data all right
um so after that the turn we can align
the sequencing leads back to the genome
to see where the airline
and this is the basis for the actual
varying point
so for the alignment we use a tool
called bwa man
and so here we need to select a
reference genome and
for most organisms we are ready for
typical model organisms
we provide indexes of
genomes that you can use but in our case
uh we're using samsung 2 and maybe
you're working with a non-reference team
so um sorry non-modern organisms
so you can also select to build a custom
index and we're going to do that
so here you will say that we are going
to select the relevant student from the
history so this
um we only have is faster family history
so this is pre-selected
um we have a paired collection
and we want to use class b and here we
have multiple data
with fit but we want to run the last
class p1 here and
that is all you need to do here there
are much more many more options
so again x2 typically has all the
options that are available
on the command line but we also try to
keep it simple
so we have some presets and actually bwa
them also has these same presets
that is great you can run
let's go now and another thing to point
out i
skipped ahead here um is that
notice that we ran we downloaded three
accessions and we're doing
this uh for each of the three data sets
because this is a connection
the jobs run for um
every tool execution runs for each
individual item and connection so
if you ever think well this is too much
clicking in galaxy
put things in a collection and
everything will be done for
each element within the connection and
it also automatically keeps the name
um so we can see for instance here this
is the accessions we have previously so
there's no way that we can mix
another thing that is great about
galaxies you don't need to wait until
the job is run and finish and green to
continue
so if i'm fasting i can demonstrate this
so the next step on after alignment is
removing duplicate reads so pcr
duplicates or
optical duplicates for this we're going
to
locked use from the pikachu suite
so while that runs um there have been
several questions
in the q a that aren't either directly
relevant to what marius was talking
about at the time
or about something we've talked about
earlier we're answering those questions
in q a
but on via text so be sure to check that
out
sorry mary's okay thank you and again
keep the questions commented in all
questions
um all right um
[Music]
so one thing i i also skipped ahead and
again
there is tutorials on this but uh you
have
multiple ways to use data sets so you
can have a single data set which is
like the initial this data set this data
set that is just one single entity
this is how you would run on a single
entity
you can run on multiple of these similar
entities or you can run on a connection
so whenever i'm running these things in
parallel i'm using
this little button here and you see it's
already pre-selected
here and we don't need to wait
for for the data set to finish we can
already hit execute
while the tool is already running that i
am too slow
to actually get there so galaxy is
faster than i can explain
which is a good thing um so the only
setting
here that we need to change from the
default is we want to
remove the duplicates right away so
typically
you would keep the duplicates but have
your varying color take care of
um not overestimating the amount of
leads
but here we will say yes and then we
keep going
all right um after this step
we can generate some
basic statistics about the alignment and
for this we're going to use
stats
and note that i am usually not
using the sections as as they are
here because galaxy has
many many many tools and you can find
them by topic
by section but if you're following the
tutorial it's much easier to just
search
um okay so uh this time it seems that
i still have some time to actually run
the tool so we
select um the duplicate output
um
okay it's a coverage distribution to
know
the summary file you don't want to
filter
all right
um okay so the next step is
realigning the leads so often in um
when you have insertions or deletions
there are sometimes equally good options
for the aligner to place
and reference you know and
to have common set of coordinates there
is a realignment step
um that one can do and this is
especially important when calling
uh insertions intermissions
so for this we will use low frequency
and um because it's going to do this
realignment you need the reference
genome
and as i said if we don't didn't prepare
a reference team already
you can always select history as the
source
this is our his genome and
that is all there is to
and then we need to do an additional
step before we can go on to call more
variants which is
insert uh in their qualities
[Music]
so we do that with
insert in that qualities with no freak
okay so again we have as input a
dataset collection and maybe i can just
show that when you only want to take
a single data set out of the collection
you can actually
go into the collection here and then
choose individual data sets
but we want to uniformly process our
datasets so we're not going to do this
these are the options that are
appropriate
for this additional qualities
and with that we can finally do the
actual variant column which we do with
the
variance so you see that no freak has
multiple
steps discrete steps and the preparation
of
the input data sets you can find more
information
on the profit 19 portal where you
describe in more details why
we've chosen to use notre
for calling variants on the same script
two
sequencing
okay so um as i mentioned so
you always need to select your correct
input data set here
and it will select the newest
appropriate data set so in our case
this is the this file is
correct now we need to set the correct
options
again we need to provide a reference
team from the history
we're going to call the variants across
the entire reference
but there is an option to specify just
a subset of the regions we're going to
call
smbs and insertions deletions
um we're going to set some additional
options we're going to say that we want
as a minimum
average 50 so meaning
sites that have less than 50 weeks will
not be covered
um and at the base form quality
we are saying that the minimum quality
should be 30
for both reference and alternative
phrases
um so this setting is important to
[Music]
make sure that you're not calling
ambiguous
alignments and
so again um these are settings that
need some additional explaining but
that's that's really the scope
of the tutorial for today
[Music]
all right
so this is the action um
the next step after the variant calling
so the very column will output a
vcf file which is a standard format
for describing variants and you can
visualize them in the gmail browser
so um galaxy has integrations for igb
for trackster okay this is built in
genome browser
for jbrowse and others
um and it's also very easy to end and
should not be sufficient okay so the
next step
is that we will run slip f which is a
tool that
looks at the variant and predicts what
effect
the variant actually has
okay and there are two synthetic
variants so there is a special version
just for
sales for two which takes care of the
multiple overlapping
leading frames that are in these two
genomes so we're going to use this one
as input we need to select the pcf file
we just
generated it is in this format
the genome is already correct we want to
create
a pc app again um we also
uh sorry
yes correct um we will also
create a c here which you can later use
to generate as
a summary report we will not add any
upstream advanced
intervals this is an option that is more
appropriate when you are looking at
genomic variants
from nonviolent sequences
um options
okay and the other options
um we don't care about these things
okay so sniffer f describes the effect
that the
given mutation has and
we can we can we can open a dcm file now
just to give you an idea how this works
there you can see not seen this before
uh so you had your chromosome on your
font
um you have a position um you have some
optional things so you can give variance
and led but we're not doing this
and then you have the reference base and
you have the internet
ultimate base you have a
quality column you can apply filters in
case you did apply some filters
um you will have here either pass or
fail
this is an optional column so you may
also have just have a dot which
you know it's optional columns and then
you have
various information so details for depth
af
is alien frequencies of what fraction of
alternate
[Music]
bases are supported by these compared to
the properties
um and then you have the type of
uh variant and simulation information
but um
this doesn't really tell you yet what is
the effect that it has to change
is it a synonymous variant does it make
introduce stocks
um so for this we've used snippets
you can see right here um it does add
this information
within this info column here but again
that is not
super easy to read so now
we can use snapchat which
generates a table from this pcf just
with the information
that we
[Music]
there are some additional uh things that
are interesting that we want to
extract so these are given giving the
tutorial
all right so this is
the last step that generates data and
now we're
going to summarize what we've generated
so far using
multi-qc which is a very great
tool for generating these kind of
reports
[Music]
so we have results from class p which
was
um okay so even copy pasting
is not always fruitful and
before um but another thing
you know when things go wrong you want
to understand what is going on so this
is very nice i can actually show you
that
um if i don't know what is going on here
i could hit this button here to submit a
back report
and somebody from our team
will respond and let you know what we're
drawing so you could say
hello i tried
[Music]
so we receive this report we look at
this uh we try to help you
um however we can um
it also already says here uh
that there was an exception so um you
see here incomplete h
rom not found in this initiative
um so we actually don't need the help
and in fact we can use the vlan button
this is
a very cool feature in galaxy so that
discloses all parameters in the database
for the disability reasons
and so if something goes wrong or you
want to change the parameter
and just the same parameter you can hit
this rearrange button
um and so all you need to do here is
change
h1 to chrome
and then we can run again
time to keep things
all right so back to multi qc so we have
a fast p
report and there is only one
data set that is compatible so it's very
easy to select this
[Music]
we also have a samples report from
simple stats
so this is this data set here
and we have
[Music]
snippet record which is
this thing i said here
okay so while multi-qc is going
we can have a look at the tables so um
this is
considerably more friendly than the pc
app so this is
your regular table that you could
or you download move here um
so um see here which
data set this is and i'm always opening
just the first one but you can see that
there is a varying number
of
number of lines in the data set and this
corresponds to
the number of variants that we
found and we see here the impact so
um yeah for instance here
some low impact mutations
variants where we take the sun
and we have a similar use coding
mutation
or we have some things that are more
severe but typically the more severe
things have
lower frequencies within the sample they
were quite rare
um okay
so let's see okay so let me take you
soon we put this down
so it gives us a global overview of what
we've done and we can
make the display here and we can make
the tool kind of get a little bit more
space
um and so these are some general
statistics
um you can see uh
various things here so um for instance
um one data set had a high level of
duplication so
perhaps it was uh sequenced very deep
um we can also see that they're not
percent of matrix is going to be low
so this might indicate that maybe
there's some human reads that are within
this mixture
there's few proper pairs which again
might highlight that
human rates have been artificially
removed
and we can see
where um
mutations fall we can see the impact
that mutations have
um you can see
whether we have frame shift so
but keep in mind this is an unfiltered
list and typically you would
do some additional features
[Music]
okay you can see how many
reads we have so this is the largest
data set this is smallest data set
um
are there any additional questions to
answer
there were a lot of questions while you
were talking
so most of them have been answered in
the q a
i currently have one open question from
pablo in the trimming step
does galaxy identify automatically all
sorts of adapter sequences that may be
present or should we specify them
if you know them it's always better to
specify them explicitly
uh if you don't know them it does
recognize the most common
sequencing adapters but if their
prevalence is relatively low it may
not find them
i just want to add here that galaxy
doesn't identify
anything what identifies is the tools
that it has
so in this particular case we're using
fast p
which recognizes automatically some
types of illumina adapters and trims
them
there's also trimmo magic which is in
the galaxy which we didn't use in this
example
there is stream galore and particularly
in case of stars cov2 if you're using
ampliconic data
so this data sets have specific primers
that are used for amplifying in this
enriching particularly sarskoff two
sequences
and so you have to know them and there
are tools for dealing with them
specifically there is a ivr toolset for
cleaving off amplicon primers off of
these reeds
it's also in galaxy we're not showing it
as a part of this example
but it's there but in order to use it
you need to know
adapter sequences that you're using
thanks anton
uh another question from
rica uh it is it possible to form plots
in galaxy would show
us which are the common genes present in
each sample
anybody want to take that
in in relation to sarskoff too or in
general
i'm not sure um i i doubt any of us
understands exactly what to
do so in general
in general okay so
um i mean
this this is a bit difficult to answer
uh that from
a different perspective so if you wanna
see for instance
which genes have annotation you could
generate a tabular file and then there
are
tools and galaxy you could block tabular
data
there are visualizations where you can
display one axis versus the other um
these are relatively simple tools um if
you do know how to use
a studio or jupiter you can load up the
data that you generated and then use our
studio
or jupiter with a galaxy to get at that
question
and we have also we have a template we
have a wrapper of
gt plot which also lets you
display different columns different
colors
so we don't have necessarily something
specifically for genes
but as soon as you put that into a table
you can generate thoughts
thank you so we have one more
outstanding question but in the interest
of time
i'm gonna move on um let's see two
sharika
uh i'm gonna show some resources on the
last slide that
you can follow up with or if any of the
panelists want to answer that via text
feel free okay so
thank you marius that was wonderful
let's go back and i'll see if i can
share my screen
share wow i feel like i'm in the 20th
century
21st century sorry okay um
okay so these are the resources i was
referring to
uh we have a bunch from sra and a bunch
from galaxy
again these slides are available online
and we'll also post links to these
slides probably
i don't know about sra but we certainly
will from galaxy
so if you have questions about sra
that's the email at sra
lots and lots of resources at sra and
ncbi in general
really a ton of stuff there are some
links to this in the tutorial itself
there also is guidance about how to
submit data which is a very common
question
for galaxy there's a number of resources
galaxyproject.org is the community hub
it's a website about all things galaxy
and in theory it links out to all parts
of the galaxy ecosystem
a couple of places to ask questions get
help help.galaxyproject.org
is a discourse based
online forum q a forum it's quite
popular quite friendly the community
is also quite friendly if you prefer a
chat interface we use
gitter for that and that's what the
getter link takes you to
um you can ask questions there that
works well
for a lot of give and take and questions
that you can state
in a short way if it takes a long time
to describe your
your question then help might be more
useful
um i mentioned earlier there are over a
hundred use gathered 100 galaxy
instances that are publicly accessible
here are three of them which are the big
ones use galaxy.org
run by the us team use galaxy.eu
run by the european team and use
galaxy.org dot au run by the australian
team
there are also more of these in the
works there's a used galaxy belgium
for instance that's out there france
spain southeast asia
and taiwan are all in various steps of
coming along the last thing i want to
highlight is our annual conference
which is at that url we are co-locating
with
bosc this year the bioinformatics open
source conference
um it's really well it's online
obviously it's at the end of july and
it's really really affordable and no
matter where you
are in the world you can attend because
we are mirroring our content
in both hemispheres so we're hosting um
out of
toronto and we're hosting out of um
eastern australia as well so
12 hours apart everything twice each day
okay so the last slide thank you
um we'd really like to thank our ncbi
collaborators
um yuri who's on the call as is lydia
and revender
i don't know if kurt and sergey
sorry if i'm not pronouncing that
correctly are on the call or not but
they were both instrumental
in getting this to work um we'd like to
thank niaid
nhgri and nsf because they provide us
with funding
and last but certainly not least the
galaxy community and again without them
we would not be who we are and dave if i
might
just finish so this um
again we're very grateful to sra for
initiating this
and uh sra provides
it lost my zoom interface here yes so
sra provides open data
and what we're adding here we're adding
open tools and open infrastructure to
analyze this data
because if you if any of you on this
webinar decide to download 10 000 sra
data sets you will be able to do that
and you will be able to map them and to
analyze them
and so this will this will be happening
somewhere
and this is one of the reasons why we
have nsf
there because nsf funds um national
supercomputing infrastructure
and galaxy runs out of texas advanced
computing center which
allows any one of you to analyze
very large data so but so i want to
thank them and again i want to thank
sra for initiating this this is
it's it's in its early stages we're
probably going to have some problems
and so for you users it's important to
let us know what these problems are so
we can fix them thank you
thank you anton and thank you all
last um certainly not least again for
sticking with us for the whole 75
minutes of this call
and um we look forward to hearing from
you on those
contact and support channels okay
and that's it uh i'm gonna stop the
recording